انتشر مقطع فيديو على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لشاب بن سعودي يوثق بالصدفه
لحظه نجاته مع صديقه من حادث مروري اثرا
انزلاق احدى السيارات واتجهت نحوما بسبب
الامطار على طريق سريع في السعوديه نتابع
امطار خير وبركه
خالد عبد الله
اذكر الله وصلوا على النبي والحمد لله
[موسيقى]
الله الله
لا اله الا الله اللهم لك الحمد اللهم لك
الحمد
يا ربي لك الحمد اعوذ بالله
اعوذ بالله
يا ابو عبد الله سلمنا
يا ابو عبد الله
اللهم لك الحمد
[موسيقى]
على ملكه جمال افريقيا
تم القبض على وحيده ليله راس السنه بعد ان
تم اقتحام منزلها والعثور على كميه كبيره
من مخدر الكويك الكوكايين وما بالغاليه
بعدها تداولي مقاطع فيديو تظهر سقوطا ثلوج
على المسجد الحرام كشفت هيئه الارصاد
الجويه حقيقه الموضوع فقد اوضح المتحدث
باسم المركز الوطني للارصاد الجويه
السعوديه حسين القحطاني ان الفيديو
المتداول لتساقط الثلوج غير صحيح كما اضعف
ان المقطع المنتشر معالج بمؤثرات اضافيه
[موسيقى]
تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو لابن يقوم بتحضير الحليب لطفله وسط
مجلس رجال يعتقد انه في السعوديه تصرف
الوالد اثار الكثيره من الردود بين
الاشاده والنقد ورد الرجل على الانتقادات
قائلا ان حضور طفل كان برغبه مني وتصرف
طبيعي والانسان يسوي ما تملي عليه نفسه
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء اليوم